welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the rise
of Skywalker right around the corner I
thought I'd dive into one of the big
theories that is floating around the
internet right now which is that Anakin
Skywalker will return for episode 9
Anakin though not in the sequel trilogy
at all up until this point this still
played a pretty big role with a lot of
kylo ren's mindset being centered around
the way that he believes Darth Vader was
kylo even owned his grandfather's helmet
as a reminder that the dark side was
deeply rooted in his family but does
that mean that the character will return
and if so how will he do it well
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the major teasers that show
that Hayden Christensen will be
returning as well as what the leaks say
about the characters come back there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything about the
movie then I highly suggest that you
turn off now
I'll leave the leaks to last as we don't
know how true that they are and I'd
rather get into the cold hard facts
first
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
whether Anakin will return for episode 9
ok so as I mentioned earlier in the
video Anakin Skywalker is a pretty big
character in terms of Star Wars
mythology and his shadow has loomed
large over the new trilogy pretty much
dictating a lot of the actions that his
grandson takes from beyond the grave
whether it's the way that he would have
wanted things to go or not from all of
the marketing materials and interviews
with people like JJ Abrams and those
that have worked on the rise of
Skywalker it's clear that they are
planning something special that ties the
entire saga together this has been
stated numerous times by numerous people
and because of it fans have speculated
that Anakin Skywalker will indeed be
making a return in one form or another
Anakin was there from the beginning and
he quickly became the main focus of the
prequel trilogy before emerging as the
big bad for the original films which
spanned from a new hope to Return of the
Jedi the majority of the events in the
saga have centered around him in one way
or another with his son Luke Skywalker
becoming a powerful Jedi and his
daughter and grandson
both making their mark across the
universe thus there isn't really a
better character to have cameo in the
rise of Skywalker as a way to tie
together the entire saga and to link
this one with the prequels the upcoming
movie titled rise of the skywalker is
clearly paying homage to just how
important the lineage years so it makes
sense to at least have the person that
it all really started with making an
appearance there's also evidence that
Hayden Christensen is hinting at the
fact that he might return with the actor
posting recently that he visited
galaxy's edge at Disneyland
Christensen was seen posing in front of
the Millennium Falcon and operating the
controls of the ship before gifting a
blue lightsaber to a fan now I'm not a
complete idiot despite what some of you
say in the comments and no way do I
believe that this confirms he's back
just because he pitted a theme park for
a film that he happened to work on but
Disney weirdly enough retweeted the post
referring to Hayden as the chosen one
before promptly deleting it which is a
bit suspect again this doesn't confirm
anything however some fans believe that
this was posted to remind fans that
there is still potential that Anakin
could bring balance to the force as was
prophesized and that he may indeed still
have a big part to play in addition to
this Christensen was also supposed to
appear alongside Ian McDiarmid back in
August at the fan X convention in Salt
Lake City however just before it was
about to begin
Disney had the panel closed down which
you caused prompted more speculation now
I'm gonna be getting into the leaks from
this part of the video so if you don't
want to know anything about the ending
of the movie or what could potentially
happen and I highly suggest that you
turn off now are you still here grey
then the force is strong with you okay
so originally the leaks say that at the
end of the film the ghost of Palpatine
was going to possess one of the Knights
of Ren played by none other than Matt
Smith who would then take on the role of
Palpatine and be the big bad however
this was rumoured to be unpopular
in-house at Disney and thus during the
confirmed reshoots that we know happened
this year
Ian McDiarmid was put back in the film
as the villain once more reprising his
role as Palpatine we know from the
trailers and the post says that the
Emperor is back and those that have seen
the leaked images of the ending know
that the
out there is 100% returning it is
possible that these reshoots happened
around the time of the phonics
convention and thus Disney cancelled the
panel just in case any leaks dropped
about the pair now in the film itself
there is rumored to be a moment in which
Luke and Rey are meditating in the Jedi
Temple with one another during Rage
training Luke apparently tells Rey of a
story that retroactively Lee changes at
CERN the element of the last Jedi and
the force awakens that is during the
scene in which Luke was about to kill
Ben solo Anakin's voice sounded off in
his head and reminded him that it is not
the way of the Jedi to strike people
down like this Luke then goes on to say
that this saved him from turning to the
dark side and that during a lot of his
training Lucas being guided by his
father's voice because he does not want
him to go down a dark path we know from
the end of Return of the Jedi that Luke
can indeed see Anakin and there is a
possibility that he could still be in
contact with him through the force Luke
says that whilst he was on the island
which we saw the character living in
self-imposed exile that he too like Rey
was often pulled to the cave and the
dark side of it but his father's
guidance always pulled him out of it in
the end he decided to close himself off
from the force due to the worry that he
would always be pulled towards the dark
and thus he shut things off the leaks
also say that later in the movie when
Rey goes to take down Palpatine that she
finds herself quickly outmatched by the
villain now we do know from leaked
images that during this she teams up
with kylo these are all floating about
on Google and they basically show the
two standing side by side with blue
lightsabers one of them is Luke's and we
can guess are the others as Anakin's as
that's one of the major blue lightsabers
in the saga both are still quite easily
bested though by the extremely powerful
Sith Lord and in order to be Tim Rey has
to tap into the force which involves
reaching out to Anakin Luke Yoda obi-wan
and lots of Jedi over the saga who all
channeled their energy and helped to
eventually take down Palpatine
originally we were meant to see these
characters but the most recent leaks
said that the reshoots removed these in
place of just having their voices
similar to how Rey heard them in the
force awakens when retrieving Luke's
lightsaber that isn't the end of the
movie though and we have seen more
leaked images that show kylo Ren
on Tatooine at the end of the film and
this supports the ending leak which
states that Rey and the gang returned to
Tatooine and that we see that she has
dismantled Luke and Anakin's lightsaber
in order to create a new one with the
yellow blade at the foot of Luke's old
home she buries the remaining parts and
then apparently the current occupiers of
the house step outside and ask who she
is she introduces herself as Mary Sue I
mean sorry
Rey Skywalker which means that she has
adopted the moniker of a mentor and is
now taking this forward carrying the
mantle she then goes to the hill and
stares out at the twin sunsets which is
when the camera pans and similar to the
ending of Return of the Jedi we see many
of the force ghosts that were teased
earlier watching her this is apparently
where the appearance of Hayden
Christensen is anakin happens and with
obi-wan Yoda and Luke they stand and
smile as Rey looks out over a galaxy
newly embodied with hope and that's what
the leaks say happened and though they
should all be taken with a pinch of salt
actually think that they make a lot of
sense going off the images that we've
seen Disney are definitely going to try
and endgame this and it makes sense for
them to bring back a pivotal character
for the final film in the skywalker saga
though I can't say with complete
certainty that this is going to be the
way that the film goes and that Anakin
is definitely returning I think that the
way that Disney have been acting coupled
with Hayden Christensen's schedule and
the leaks makes it seem like there is a
really good chance that he will be back
JJ is trying to write a lot of the
wrongs of the last Jedi and the Luke
scene that I mentioned earlier as well
as the send-off of the series definitely
seems like a great way to close
everything with a satisfying ending how
it plays out we will see but it has got
me slightly more enthusiastic about the
movie as I think it would be the cherry
on top to see Anakin come back even if
it's just for a cameo now will this
please the fans I don't know we all know
that no one hates Star Wars more than
Star Wars fans but it will be
interesting to see if JJ manages to
stick the landing with this as deep down
I kind of hope that he does even if I've
lost a lot of love for Star Wars over
the past five years now if you're
watching this from the future and have
already seen the movie then you know
what you need to do
tell us in the comments below because we
all want to know if you're not from the
future and are just as clueless as the
rest of us and make sure you comment
below and let me know if you think
Anakin will return and if you enjoy this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of all over the theories
surrounding Rey about who her parents
could be we go top to bottom on the best
ones and discuss the leaks as well so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me up to the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey
or head over to my discord server which
should be linked in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with all the latest videos on
the channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we'll also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
boxer on blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning it's like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Anakin's return in the comments section
below but when is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of November and the
cell be shipped out from the end whoever
gets the prize it's best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were made into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]